on l'appelle le grand homme est depuis
novembre
il est en colère
une éruption comme on n'en avait pas vu
depuis 50 ans à l'époque
l'archipel était encore une colonie
portugaise le grand homme crache le feu
sur son île feu c'est justement le nom
de l'île fogo en portugais
l'île tout entière est né du volcan
mais ce n'est pas l'enfer sur terre fogo
est un petit paradis
[Musique]
tout pousse à l'ombre du grand homme
malgré les risques les habitants de
l'île veulent rester voici quelques-uns
de ses indéracinable alcine d'eau
d'abord guy des paysans c'est l'insoumis
et ses frères jouant le sentimental
purina l'impassible c'est le philosophe
sans oublier l'oncle moïsi ce toujours
d'accord i
c'est l'oncle liesse s'est pas fermé non
tir pâtir barreau choisies ferme
c'est une expédition qu'il rêvait de
faire depuis le début de l'éruption
mais il fallait attendre que le volcan
retrouve son calme
aujourd'hui ils peuvent remonter
ensemble au village retrouvez des
maisons qu'ils ont dû quitter
et même si le volcan a sans doute tout
ravagé au cap vert c'est souvent en
musique qu'on accepte son destin
on est presque arrivé
[Musique]
le voici le grand homme un cône de 2800
mètres de haut à chaque fois que j'y
reviens je ressens le soulagement et le
bonheur d'être enfin chez moi
la température le paysage le volcan tout
est magique
il faut toujours avoir conscience que
c'est dangereux de vivre aux pieds la
vole quand on sait qu'il peut exploser à
n'importe quel moment mais on peut rien
y faire
on est tellement petit face à lui tu
qu'on peut pas volcan qui décide
la voiture ne peut pas aller plus loin
dupont
voici la coulée qui a chassé alcine dos
et ses frères
m
la force de la nature ont cousu imagine
assez juste inimaginable
inimaginable au fond c'est incroyable y
cueillir nhk j'aime bien me dire que
nous aussi on a cette force et que c'est
le volcan qui nous la donne du vide du
fourgon mousse
et salue mon pote qu'est ce que tu fais
tu te reposes le squelette et avait une
vraie maison
le grand homme l'a englouti mais il ne
lui a pas tout prix c'est la porte de la
maison qui a été détruite
jules temps la récupérer juste avant
qu'elle ne brûle je savais déjà que
j'allais reconstruire derrière ça ce
sont des poutres en bois que j'ai
récupéré d'une ancienne étable
j'ai récupéré tout ce que j'ai pu pour
reconstruire cette baraque de toute
façon toute notre vie est ici pour nous
partir ce serait comme forcer un animal
à vivre en dehors de son habitat naturel
nous on est habitué à vivre ici le
problème c'est qu'on construit les
maisons sur son chemin mais le volcan
lui il n'y peut rien il ne dérange
personne
ça reste notre grand ami vraiment
village lentement mais inexorablement
elle a englouti les maisons les unes
après les autres avant de s'essouffler
quelques dizaines de mètres plus loin
depuis les gens reviennent pour ramasser
les dernières récoltes récupérer un
meuble ou un souvenir
ainsi nos et les siens ont fait le
chemin pour ça leur hôtel enfin ce qu'il
en reste
la famille avait mis dix ans à
construire l'hôtel inauguré au printemps
détruit à l'automne parfois je me dis
que ce sont des choses qui arrivent mais
c'est dur de voir l'endroit où on a
passé les meilleurs moments de notre vie
détruit comme ça c'est triste
je pense que je vais enlever les tuiles
tout de suite et davies et l'armature
parce que s'il pleut le bois va prendre
la pluie et ça va s'abîmer
oui tu as raison les plans sont en bon
état on va pouvoir tout refaire ouais
son souci il ya eu l'éruption j'ai tout
voulu laisser ici parce que toute ma vie
tout cet hôtel je l' ai gagnée grâce au
volcan ça comme guide ou comme paysan
échouent chaque centime que j'ai investi
dans cet hôtel c'était le volcan qui me
l'avait donné aujourd'hui il a tout
repris mais je suis convaincu qu'il me
leur donnera demain
la vie recommence tu vois avant
l'éruption j'avais les cheveux longs
après tout ce qui s'est passé je les
écoutais c'est le symbole d'un nouveau
départ parce qu'en fait je les avais
déjà courrier disant quand on a commencé
l'hôtel
maintenant je regarde le futur
[Musique]
alcine d'eau et les siens se sont déjà
attaqués au chantier ce matin il trace
un nouveau chemin d'accès waouh c'est
chaud c'est une façon de se réapproprier
leur village je pense que ça serait
mieux de les casser un peu plus pour
demain revenir nous on l'est tous de la
même famille et le chemin qui nous
conduira notre hôtel on le fera ensemble
charles haas calderas notre village
c'est chez nous où on est né ici on
l'agrandît on ne sait pas on va mourir
mais on appartient à cet endroit
nous on est les fils du volcan
[Musique]
ce soir les fils du volcan vont dormir
sur place
dans cette sorte d'igloo en pierre de
lave
[Musique]
et ils se sont lancé un défi
cuisiner un repas 100% volcanique et le
partager tous ensemble dans le cratère
tout va dépendre de la cueillette
même si ici les champs sont des champs
de lave
[Musique]
sur ces arbustes des haricots
mais c'est sous la terre que se trouve
le plat de résistance le manioc
merci manioc nos coeurs vont avoir un
réflexe de paysans il garde une partie
du manioc pour le replanter aussitôt on
voit qu'ici les plantes se développent
plus vite
elles sont plus vigoureuse qu'ailleurs
on a même plus de récoltes mal dessiné
c'est de la bonne terre les cendres
volcaniques agissent comme un isolant
elle empêche l'eau de s'évaporer c'est
pour ça que quand on creuse le sol en
dessous est toujours humide
[Musique]
bientôt le manioc corps a déjà repoussé
à moins que la lave ne mange aussi ce
terrain là comment peut-on rester léger
quand on vit sur un volcan
peut-être parce qu'ici tout est à portée
de main même le combustible qui va
servir à cuire le dîner
[Musique]
au menu ce soir farandole de manioc avec
ses haricots du volcan et son poulet à
la braise
il y aura même du café un autre cadeau
du volcan torréfié sur place alors moïse
isme tu commence pas à manger tranquille
tranquille on peut dire que le volcan
est un deuxième dieu parce qu'ils nous
donnent tout il suffit d'avoir un peu de
force et un peu de courage pour en
profiter on peut vivre bien ici au cap
vert aussi tout finit par des chansons
celles ci alcine de ses frères l'ont
écrite et composée eux-mêmes 1015
pavaner les mines casta ben ali
mais castanet des véhicules toujours
mais casta valide et efficace tabarez
tabary
m
guaino
bautista vie tout à cannes et dans la
course au sacre à vail a dit non non 15
comme un délit
[Musique]
nle